the president of the German Institute
for Economic Research joins us now
Marcel focaccia a lot of opposing views
there what do you think is this free
trade deal feasible it is feasible but
we will see a very tough negotiation
period ahead of us because Europe and
United States are fundamentally
different in their structure in their
strength you're much more based on a big
industry and the United States much
stronger in services and getting a joint
agreement means compromise and that will
be very difficult to reach and if those
compromises are made what sort of way is
this going to what sort of direction are
we going to be taken in as far as jobs
go for example both sides were going to
benefit from it both will generate jobs
in the United States probably possibly a
little bit more than in Europe but also
in Germany and in Europe overall we will
see more job growth even though it will
not be a big game changer economic
growth as well slide economic growth
slightly more even though it will take
many years to really fully pass through
but we will see higher growth as well
yes and what about standards that's the
one that consumers seem to be worried
about yes there will be an adjustment of
standards that means that Europe cannot
have it its way all the way the same for
the United States so we will have to
come to a compromise but ultimately I'm
convinced it will be good for consumers
more competition common standards will
mean lower prices and that ultimately
benefits the consumer and more
competition does that also mean a whole
lot more products the product variety
will certainly increase but we will also
see a change in standards in Europe
partly adjusting to what the United
States is doing so definitely it's both
the price it will go down in the variety
of elm trees so if there are all of
these benefits why a German so worried
that it going to be force-fed chlorine
treated chickens for example yes I mean
having a deal means a compromise some
will benefit some will have a cost not
everyone will benefit from their deal
there will be industries and sectors in
Europe that will see lower employment
and that will have a hard time competing
with the United States
same as vice versa so not everyone is
benefiting and compensating the losers
is a big big part of the negotiation but
why all of the bad press I mean there
are so many stories out there saying
this is going to change standards are
going to go down people are going to
have to deal with the market being
flooded with these chlorine treated
chickens which is the way Americans
treat their chickens and some European
nations as well but it's banned here in
Germany look when you have a compromise
not everything is perfect right so you
will have certain things you will have
preferred less but there will be lots of
benefits in particular in terms of
prices for the consumers in terms of
jobs in terms of growth so overall the
net is really a benefit for Europe and
the United States what about countries
outside Europe in the United States like
Australia it just this week sign up a
free-trade deal with South Korea also
Japan and it's doubling its efforts it
says to sign up a free trade deal with
China um we're seeing a lot of movement
in the asia-pacific all of a sudden yes
I think that's where the main weakness
of the bilateral deal with the United
States is it's much preferable to have a
global deal because for Europe Asia is a
much more important trading partner than
the United States the same for the u.s.
it trades a lot more with Asia and the
danger is that we will have less trade
with Asia and with other countries
because of that bilateral deal so the
first best the preferable solution would
really be a global trade deal with the
World Trade Organization but that
unfortunately has not been realized so
far but still in the future I would wish
that we move more toward this
multilateral agreement than the Spile
actual one it's the flatter thank you
very much for your analysis